hello everyone and welcome to another
interest in game this time from the 1965
US Championship here we have a game
between Bobby Fischer with the white
piece and pal Benko the last time we had
a bank of Fischer brawl was at the time
I was covering the 1959 candidates
tournament and as you all know in that
tournament Fischer didn't lose a single
game against Banco he won both of his
games with the white pieces and drew two
of his games with the black pieces so
this game is very interesting how at one
point Banco makes a weird decision and
the Fischer really really really takes
most out of the position and there's a
very interesting puzzle for you to solve
so I do I do hope you enjoy it and
another thing oh yeah
gonna save that for later here is a nice
photo of Bobby Fischer also from 1965 I
don't think it's from this tournament
but then again it might be so I just
wanted to share that and I also have a
nice photo of Bobby Bobby Fischer on the
phone also from 1965 but definitely not
from this tournament it's from some
tournament where he defeated the Viktor
Korchnoi or so they say an unchaste news
Russia that's where the photo is from so
okay that being said let's let's see
this game what we opens with E for s to
be expected we have e 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 Dora Lopez
a6 morphe defense by up to a 4 Knight to
f6 Fischer castles Bishop to e7 rook to
e1 all standard Theory b5 Bishop to b3
b6 we have c3 Benko castles h3 Knights
the b8 nice to be hit with the idea of
making room for this point so the pawn
can be pushed to c5 and later this night
will come to b6 where it will support c4
very nicely so d4 Knight B to d7 next to
h4 by Fischer preparing to bring this
Knight over to a 5 hour it will be a
very dangerous piece black will either
have to push g6
to kick it away from a 5-week in his
position or or he will have to give up
his light square bishop so Fisher will
win the bishop bear nice to be six as
planned
Knight the D to c5 we have D captors and
c5 d captors and now Knight to f5 and
here Bishop captures and I fight was
played now like I said if you wanna kick
it away you could play g6 but you're
still losing the bishop pair white can
simply play Knight captures Queen
captures and after Knight to f3 you have
a whole lot of dark square weaknesses
around the King and the whites plan will
be very clear here so after Knight to f5
Bishop captures and now he captures on
f5 Queen to c7 and now Fischer plays g4
h6 now comes h4 and C for blocking this
Bishop soul this and it's not really the
attack on the F pawn but the the pin
could be very uncomfortable in the
future so Bishop to see two and now
Knight to h7 kind of preparing to
prevent Fischer from pushing g5 + f6 in
the future knife to f3 now f6 is played
and okay Bank who did the men who did
lock the pawns on the inside but those I
mean if you look at this that this
really doesn't seem like the king is
very safe here so nice to be too we have
rook a to d8 and now Queen to f3 I'm
pinning so now the night is ready to
enter the game and here a banco should
definitely do something like rook to d7
prepared to double up on the d file and
really decide where to go from there but
this is what I meant in the beginning
here banco decides to play h5 sorry
instead of rook to d7 here banco decided
to play h5 and it's a kind of a weird
decision he's giving up a pawn on the
Kings side probably to kind of kind of
destroy a Fischer's nice upon setup here
but there's really no I mean there's
really no good reason to do this and as
you'll see in the game banco doesn't
show us what the reason for this move
was so Knight to d5
and here official place nine three four
you could probably push h6 immediately
and maybe the result will be the same
but there's no reason to do this you can
always push h6 first Fisher plays in
Knight to e4
we have Knight to f4 and now Bishop
captures on f4 pawn captures and now
King to h1 and this is the strongest
move Fisheries preparing the G file for
his rook and then for the other rook as
well so King to h8 we have looked the g1
and now rook to f7 Benko is preparing to
defend the g7 point as he knows what
what visuals plan is so rook to g6 and
what do you play here well if you try
something like Knight to f/8 simply kick
away the rook you're gonna be this is
will be met with h6 so what's the idea
here if you play Knight captures on g6
you get F captures and now what do you
do you move the rook you get Queen to h5
and there is no defense against H
captures on g7 this will be checkmate I
there's really no move here you could
move the King but then again you capture
and again Queen to h7 this will be
checkmate
so after this rook to g6 we have Bishop
to d6 banco tries it this way now comes
rock 8 2 G 1 and now Bishop to f8
Fischer pushes h6 and here Queen to e5
was played if you play G captures on h6
of course you get rock - GA - this will
be checkmate but another interesting
idea is instead of this Queen to e5 move
that banco played you could try rug d to
d7 simply add more pressure - more
defense to the g7 pawn but this will be
met with h5 in the future when you
capture the point you will always have
the h6 move and after black makes a
couple of moves as he doesn't have that
many moves to make for example come to
b7 you get H captures rook after son g7
Queen captures on f4 as you do have time
to even grab a pawn
Queen to d5 black does have to make some
moves and now Queen to g4 white is
simply preparing when he will push h6 or
when he will capture so twin back to b7
now f3
now the knight can move Queen to d5 and
now h6 route captors and e6 pawn captors
on g6 and now f5 attacking the Queen and
the night here
so g7 check King moves and now Queen to
g6 and the strongest move Queen to f7
and here you have this is the position I
wanted you to check out it's only the
first puzzle of this game so feel free
to pause the video get a couple of
seconds and try to find the strongest
move in this position for white so I
hope you were successful in doing it for
those of you who found the move
congratulations you're an excellent
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show here the idea
would be Queen captures on h7 width
check team captures and now Knight to g5
check King moves and now not capture the
Queen but rather h7 with check King
moves and only now Knight captures on f7
and now if you capture the knight then
white will get another Queen and if you
capture the pawn then Bishop captures on
f5 and this and this will be checkmate
actually the King has nowhere to go so
quite a quite a nice little puzzle
so after h6 Benko tried Queen to e5 we
have Queen to g4 by Fischer Brooke D to
d7 so pretty much the same idea maybe
with a different move order f3 by
Fischer and now Bishop to c5 attacking
Fischer's broken g1 Fisher captures the
Bishop Knight captures Queen captures
and now we have rook captures on g7 rook
captures H captures and g7 would check
King to g8 and now Queen to g6 by
Fischer with ideas of playing Queen to
e8 so a bank of defense rocked to the
8th and now Fischer plays Bishop to e4
Bishop to e4 is a very deadly move and
it has a very deadly idea it might seem
like a mysterious move but you'll see
very soon wife Esther played this and
there really isn't a good move here for
Benko in the game banker played Queen to
c8 and here we have another position
where I want you to pause the video and
find the Fisher's
brilliant idea after which Banco
resigned the game so this is the
position for free deposit
and you know give it as usual a couple
of seconds or more if you like
so for those of you who are able to
solve it congratulations and for those
who just want to enjoy the show here at
Fisher play Queen to e8 to check and
what do you do here I will obviously
can't move the King if you play
something like night to f8 you're not
going to have too much fun simply quick
bringing another queen into the game
King to h7 and now Queen to g7 and this
is this will be checkmate
but after Queen to e8 this is actually
where Benko resigned the game because if
you actually capture the Queen then you
get Bishop to d5 check the King has
nowhere to go you have to block this
rope to the six now Bishop captures
again with the check you can't move the
King Queen has the capture and now pawn
captures and as you can see black
doesn't have a move the pawns are
creating a wall here so the King can't
approach the past one and if you play
something like f5 maybe make room for
the night and then simply rook to g6 and
again black has no moves the white was
simply play East 7 and then win the game
with a 8 so yeah but after Queen to
eight like I said banker resigned the
game and I wonderful a wonderful victory
for free young Bobby Fischer here and as
as usual I did prepare the final
standings of this tournament so let's
just check it out
so Fisher of course one Attwood 8 and I
have points then we have Robert bind
then similar chef's key then Bernard
Zukerman William Edison any clothes
rustling mo Larry Evans then Anthony CED
pal Benko r2 biscaia carl burger and
duncan saddles so yeah that was the game
I do hope you enjoyed it it's only one
game from the 1965 USA championship but
it's like I said it was one of the
suggestions so I decided to show this
one as well and I will make a poll on my
channel maybe through maybe through
community posts or maybe through some
other social media I don't know we'll
see which which social media has the
best poll settings where you will be
able
vote which which series should I maybe
cover next
which tournament or you know well we'll
just see where to go from here so like I
said I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check doing my previous videos
here I think you'll for watching and I
will see you soon probably with another
one of your suggestions so thank you